this is a map of San Francisco there's a
lot of plots on that you may be asking
what is that plotting I have no doubt
that whatever clip I'm about to play of
Ronda Sanz is going to make total sense
according to the Department of Housing
and Urban Development uh these are the
numbers for the homeless population in
each of your states it is a big problem
around the country in the state of
California it is
172,000 in Florida it is 26,000 uh I ask
you why the disparity what are the
policies you are implementing that is
different from that of California
California is adopting leftist policies
Gavin Newsome was uh Governor or uh
mayor of San Francisco he put out a
10-year plan like 20 years ago he was
going to end homelessness then a few
years later he had another plan and now
he says he's going to do and it's only
gotten worse in the last 10 years in
California the homeless has gone up 45%
it's gone down in Florida 45% but it's
caused a huge problem with quality of
life in in California the people that
flee always bring up this they've really
empowered lawlessness and drug use and
you know Gavin new one point tried to
say that California was the freedom
State I just kind of laugh like you're
locking people down you're doing all
this but then I thought about it you
know California does have freedoms uh
that some people don't uh that other
states don't you have the freedom to
defecate in public in California you
have the freedom to pitch a tent on
Sunset Boulevard you have the freedom to
create a homeless encampment under a
freeway and even lighted on fire you
have the the freedom to have an open air
drug market and use drugs you have a
freedom if you're illegal alien to get
all these taxpayer benefits so so those
are freedoms they're not the freedoms
our founding fathers Envision but they
have contributed to the destruction of
the quality of life in California and
the results speak for themselves people
are leaving the state because they have
failed in addressing the homeless
population we are investing
unprecedented resources more
accountability we've gotten 68,000
people off the streets close to 6,000
encampments we've gotten off the streets
we've also invested in unprecedented
resour resources in reforming our
Behavioral Health System Ron has
literally the worst mental health system
in America forgive me outside of of
Mississippi and Texas and so with all
due respect to being lectured on some of
these topics Ronda San is not the one
I'm going to be list 30 second response
you're uh well I'm looking at total time
Governor dis about needs it this is a
map of San Francisco there's a lot of
plots on that you may be asking what is
that plotting well this is an app where
they plot the human feces that are found
on the Streets of San Francisco and you
see how almost the whole thing is
covered because that is what has
happened in one of the previous greatest
cities this country's ever had human
feces is now a fact of life except when
a communist dictator comes to town then
they cleaned up the streets they lined
the streets with Chinese flags they
didn't put American flags there they
cleaned everything up so they're willing
to do it for a communist dictator but
they're not willing to do it for their
own the limited time we have left I want
to get there are two very important
issues we have not
hit